foreign
[Music]
I would not call him the equivalent of
say Mao the Chinese Communist party is
not this homogeneous omnipotent kind of
power there are factions there are
reformers there are more conservative
aspects within the party itself and he
has to contend with them
[Music]
under Xi Jinping the key thing that
we're seeing is that he has put
communism he's put the party at the
Forefront of everything and so putting
the party more at the Forefront
basically allows XI jinping's leadership
and his government to prioritize other
things not just the economy and for Xi
Jinping you see movements on climate
change climate change is a key priority
that he has representation on the
international state
[Music]
foreign
the People's Republic of China is all
about having strong leaders it's a big
country and it's a very diverse country
when you're talking about a population
of 1.4 billion people it would be quite
difficult to be able to sustain a
cohesive coherent stable strong National
kind of environment without a strong
single leader at the helm foreign